[Music]
do
hi
good afternoon good evening welcome to
the table hope you all are doing well
i'm glad to see each one of you who are
able to join us here in person and i
want to welcome those of you who are
watching and attending with us online
we're glad that you're here as well as
too
i'm just going to kick us off with just
a few announcements um just so that you
guys kind of keep some dates um in your
mind so the very first one i want to
just kind of put in your mind is the
stay at the table
this is a meeting that we do about twice
a year um so this is actually kind of
important because we only we don't do it
very often um so it'd be really
important for you guys to attend or at
least some try try to be here as often
as you possibly can when we have those
but this is going to be on february the
6th uh this is going to be
where we kind of talk about all kinds of
things we've got planned for the year
we're going to talk about goals that we
have find some fight where we are
financially
um
just some changes potentially we have
just going on religious leadership just
we want to keep you aware of every all
the details that are that's going on um
with us the other thing is that that
particular evening we're not going to
have child care available so just kind
of plan
that around so that's actually just
going to be um you know after church on
that particular sunday
the other announcement is the following
sunday is our this is super bowl
oh yes yes
so that means because the super bowl
we're gonna have church about an hour
earlier than what we normally do so
that's that particular sunday works it's
going to be at four o'clock um so we can
be kind of done just a little bit
earlier so if you have other plans that
you want to participate in socially you
can continue to participate in that
socially and the church won't get in the
way
so
anyway with those uh those two are the
two biggest things um with that in mind
i'm going to just open us in prayer
lord just thank you so much for just
allowing us to come together as a body
of believers
thank you so much for just just creating
the space
where we just can come and sit at your
feet
where we can
just worship you and just be coming to
come in a place where we can just thank
you for all the different things that
are just going on our lives
also hopefully that we can get
um a sense of peace about anything
that's going on in our lives as well
knowing that you're in control that you
have a plan
and that there's a community of people
that are here
that we're not doing these journeys
alone
i pray that you just open our hearts and
minds to the words that writers is going
to be sharing with us today
and um just be with us through this time
in christ
amen
thanks dawn
all right you guys if you would stand up
um
and i wanted to start us off tonight
with a verse brett's been taking us
through first peter
and um as i was reading it i just wanted
to kind of
approach this worship time together
with um first peter 2 verse 9. it says
but you are a chosen people
a royal priesthood a holy nation
a people belonging to god
i love that phrase
that you may declare the praises of him
who called you out of darkness and into
wonderful light
once you were not a people but now you
are a people of god
once you had not received mercy but now
you have received mercy
and
um let's just hang on to those words as
we go through this set and whatever you
are feeling any negative self-talk or
unworthiness or separation that you
might sense i pray that as you sing
these words with us as we sing them
together
that you experience the acceptance and
the love of god and you hear his
heartbeat speaking over us you are holy
you are chosen you are
belonging to me
um
that's just been encouragement to me as
as i was planning this set and so i just
wanted to share that with you as we get
started
so um melody and joe and maggie if you
guys haven't met us we're gonna go ahead
and jump in but y'all please this is an
all play so please sing along as you can
[Music]
is
here's my heart lord
[Music]
can breathe
here's my heart
[Music]
lord is
can breathe
[Music]
always true
here's is
[Music]
is true
true
[Music]
cause i am found
i am yours
i am loved i'm making
i have life
i can breathe
i am healed i
[Music]
[Applause]
you are good always
[Music]
are true
you
[Music]
are everything
is
[Music]
speakers
you guys feel free to join in in our
prayers of the people and
when i get to end the end of this first
section we'll open up space and if you
would like to share a name or a
situation that you're carrying on your
heart tonight and we'll lift those up
together before god
and if you're online please join in
online you can share yours in the
comments
and then i'll close it out with a short
prayer at the end
[Music]
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember
and who care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations
up to you
those who are sick
[Music]
school teachers nurses and your school
staff
[Music]
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing
hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
you surround me
from my enemies
to all my fears are gone
i'm no
[Music]
of longer
i'm no longer
[Music]
from my mother's wounds
i've been born again
[Music]
i'm no longer
is
[Music]
cause i am a child
of
[Music]
i god
a child
of
[Music]
a god
of god
[Music]
[Applause]
you rescued me so i
[Music]
so i could walk right through it
my
[Music]
a fears
of god
i am a child of god
[Music]
and i'm no longer
cause i am a child of god
[Music]
oh i
am of god
[Music]
no
place i would rather be
i would rather be
[Music]
is
no place i would rather be
no place
[Music]
i want
more i want more
[Music]
please
i want
[Music]
more of you
god
[Music]
no
here
[Music]
so
is
[Music]
me
bless us
[Music]
flood our lives with your voice and your
truth
[Music]
and more of the words that we hear in
first peter calling us to be holy
calling us to be yours
[Music]
as we walk through each day this week
would we hear them echoing
[Music]
will we believe them
would we live as the kind of people you
created us to be
we find your goodness
would we find your purpose
your invitation
how would we follow it
would it guide us
out of darkness
and into your wonderful life
thank you for who you are thank you for
what you're doing in and through us god
thank you for each person inside this
room and outside this room god
would you be close would you be near
and would we meet with you god during
this time together
it's in your name i pray these things
thank you jesus
amen
you guys can be seated thank you for
worshiping with us and if you want to
turn to the people around you make them
feel welcome say hello and then brett
will get us started with our message
well good evening everyone
grace and peace y'all doing well
yeah doing good good caitlin's good yeah
good good
well it is a joy just a joy to be with
all of you and that of course includes
those joining us online we love you a
lot and uh and anyone here who is new
thank you so much for being here with us
um so we are in uh a series titled first
peter um part two
and um we're really just kind of walking
our way through this this remarkable
little book from the new testament so um
for those who are wondering it's not
like epically long you know if you're
like oh man we're going through this
book pretty slow is this going to take
us three years um nope but um but it
will be a few months you know as we kind
of work our way through this so we will
kind of chop it up so we're gonna do
finish chapter two and then we'll
probably take a break and then we'll
come back you know chapter three and
keep going so um so the title of my
message um tonight is make christians
peculiar again
and uh if you were here you'll hear
echoes um
of a previous message i did back in the
fall when we were in chapter one since
he's on peter's on very similar themes
but um so we're we are in first peter
chapter 2 verses 9 through 12 and uh
peter writes these words he says but you
you are a chosen people
a royal priesthood a holy nation god's
special possession
um other translations say a peculiar
people that you may declare the praises
of him who called you out of darkness
into his wonderful light in that
beautiful like i don't know if you can
relate i can relate to that you know
just out of like just my own just a mess
of a life i heard someone say that the
church um
well that the way outsiders often
perceive the church is that it is you
know somewhere where people kind of make
a rational decision to like receive some
moral training and so they you know go
to church because it's good for me
um
and that's very much i think an
outsider's perspective but um
the same person said but actually the
reality is most people go to church go
to it like uh like the for the same
reason people go to a hospital
you know like when you're really hurting
like that's where you go
you know and it's sort of similar like
it's not that we're just kind of like oh
life's going awesome you know maybe i'll
go to church it's sort of like at least
when we're initially coming to christ
it's often from a place of you know some
desperation here and so i can relate to
that out of out of the darkness into his
marvelous light
verse 10 once you were not a people
but now you are the people of god once
you had not received mercy but now you
have received mercy dear friends
i urge you as foreigners and exiles you
some of you if you're here in the fall
you recognize this language right which
is why it's make christians peculiar
again if you um if you were here in the
fall you'll remember this language of
you know foreigners exiles it's not that
they literally are they they aren't
literally like foreigners in their
country you know like they left their
home country and they immigrated to what
was his audiences in modern-day turkey
so these were folks generally from that
area like they grew up there they're not
at all foreigners and exiles but of
course right that's his point he's
addressing them he's basically saying
like you are a counter-cultural people
i'm getting ahead of myself this is my
don't wanna take my whole message all
right just read the passage brett i urge
you as foreigners and exiles to abstain
from sinful desires which wage war
against your soul live such good lives
among the pagans that though they accuse
you of doing wrong they may see your
good deeds and glorify god on the day he
visits
us where i'd like to focus is on that
that last line from verse 12. um live
such good lives among the pagans this
kind of strange language to us but just
means sort of like unbelievers or
non-believers basically those who don't
follow christ
that they though they accuse you of
doing wrong
right so they accuse you of doing wrong
and yet in the end they may see your
good deeds glorify god on the day he
visits uh some other words he's he's
sort of exhorting them
um or kind of assuming
that um
people
outside the church will kind of look at
you and your life and will
be puzzled by it right they'll almost be
the sense of like huh wait you
you believe what you think what
you're that's that's weird that's not
what i expected like that strikes me
that's uh something about that's off
like that's i don't know about that i
don't know why i thought you were on our
team i thought you were like on our
tribe but you kind of are part of our
tribe and then you're like kind of par
you're like not a part of a tribe or i'm
confused like you're not quite fitting
in to the mole that i expected of you
so he's saying like there's a certain
puzzlement here and yet
in the end
they see your good deeds they glorify
god
it reminds me of the
beautiful little turn of phrase jesus
said
wisdom will be proved right by her
actions
in other words
in the end they will see the results of
your living
and then they'll see like
oh
that will speak for itself
right i think that's kind of what he's
what he's getting at what he's naming so
um as i mentioned like here we are very
much back at all the same themes um from
chapter one with the exiles and the
foreigners and the stranger language and
you know he's doing it again although
this time he's kind of expanding it a
little more positive not just kind of
the um i don't know that the exiles and
stuff is a little more intense language
but you know it's kind of beautiful too
like this is what mindy was pointing out
in her beautiful reading it was um you
know your chosen people you're a royal
priesthood you're a holy nation you're
you're god's special possession you're
his special children he's you're um like
i mentioned other translations say
you're a peculiar people right so so you
can see it's all these kind of themes um
where he's just kind of trying to hit
home the fact that um that as christians
um we have like a particular um story
and um from that story
we have certain beliefs and values and
like practices and ways of living that
are or at least should be um different
from the surrounding culture
right that's kind of what he's what he's
getting at
and um
this i want to contend is precisely the
problem of um american christianity
um quote unquote the way we could put it
is the crisis of american christianity
is that we are no longer a peculiar
people
right there's like
there's not much that's unique
um about us and and kind of what i mean
is um
my point here isn't just to kind of i
don't know kind of beating on kind of
christians in general sort of easy to do
you know poke fun and stuff but it's i
don't mean to just poke fun in some
general sense um what i'm really trying
to get at is that
i think something's happened over the
last 30 40 years i can't really i'm not
a historian maybe before that it was
kind of like this i i don't quite think
so um
i think what's happened in the last 30
or 40 years is
um for a whole host of reasons
um
politics
has has deeply um and not just politics
that's always been true but i mean um
kind of the divide of left and right
politically and the intense tribalism
you know
i've heard rumors that in the past like
sort of um you know
liberals and conservatives were like
even in the senate could be like friends
and stuff could have meals and things
that's what i heard rumors of such a
thing we know now that's like political
suicide you're like you're friends with
the enemy and it's like pictures and
it's all over social media they're
afraid you know it's like it's just that
intense tribalism and so what's kind of
happened is it has very much made its
way into the church
not just in our own kind of personal
relationships so to some degree that's
that's true
um but i mean even in the sense that um
we are have been so kind of um we've
bought in
to those one of those two kind of
stories in tribes
you see what i mean it's sort of like
and that becomes our identity
like we are peculiar people in that
sense
we are peculiarly
conservative or we are peculiarly you
know kind of
liberal progressive like that's and that
becomes our story that becomes our
identity like that's who we are
that's what we believe and that's the
story that we tell ourselves about
ourselves it forms us powerfully we are
constantly taking in the story and the
message and um kind of the all the
messaging and propaganda of the tribe
how do we do that i mean it kind of
varies you know depending on your age
and such
but um
you know there's like the msnbc crowd
there's the um the fox news crowd
there's the um you know kind of
conservative facebook groups there's the
more progressive facebook groups there's
the same thing for twitter and you know
who you who you follow and all like the
various influencers and what happens we
like kind of buy into a certain story
and that's like our
story
are you tracking me
like it's like that's who i am
that's my story that's the animating
story of my life this it's my identity
and here's what's crazy is it never like
we've been so powerfully formed and
discipled in that tradition so to speak
in that i'll just kind of come out and
say it like sort of a religious like a
religion almost right we've been so
powerfully formed and discipled in that
um
it never even occurs to us to ask
if jesus would agree
like partly because
we just take jesus and we just we read
it's sort of like i've used the analogy
of glasses before you know when you read
the bible sort of like you always have
your interpretive lenses on you know
and that's true of any human being you
know just based on your culture where
you're from you know you kind of come to
the text and you like
you you interpret the text right and
almost what happens is it's like we we
take that story we take those either
kind of conservative glasses or those
liberal progressive glass or whatever it
is we kind of have those glasses on and
then we read jesus through the
through the text we interpret it through
the text and which is weird because
there's even like weird selective
readings that we do you know the
passages were like yes jesus is on my
side we have like a quote or something
and then we like conveniently ignore
like the five or six or a hundred other
verses that don't really align with that
but we're not going to talk about those
we're not going to preach about those
we're never going to do a sermon series
on those we're just not going to touch
on those topics whatsoever because it
doesn't align with our story
all right can you see where this happens
it's yeah it's a real problem and this
is why like this is where
people often
um kind of pigeonhole even the table as
a certain type of community and read it
through the lens of that divide those
those two stories right like oh i know
what kind of church the table is i know
it kind of like oh okay
right can you see where we and
um
but that's to that's to read the table
that's to read the church that's to kind
of force it through a grid that's like
completely foreign to it who who the
table and who the church were trying to
be i'm not saying we do this we're like
efforting
we're trying is to be like christ-like
right like that's the goal like what
kind of church is the table we're trying
to be a christ-like church
and however that ends up being
interpreted by others okay that's fine
but like that's the path we're on which
is which is why i really feel like as a
as a pastor even um
i am what i'm just a pastor i'll just
say as a christian like i'm
um i think politics matters i think how
we relate matters so don't hear me
saying like you know politics that
doesn't matter we're not doing anything
social or the church has no implications
for that no no it does and we'll get to
some of that
but um but it's like but we're not
playing that game so much we're like a
peculiar people we're trying to be the
people of god we're trying to be who
god's called us to be
together
and the way i thought about it is um
that means as christians we're like
socially engaged you know unaware
and yet
our hearts we're not like caught up in
the drama
oh it's dramatic isn't it i mean it's
just drama
constant dr it's
so over the top just dramatic and like
people are caught up in that and and
where it goes is like people get so
enthused in like crazy passion about
like build america back better
or make america great again
these are like the stories we're like
that's my tribe that's my team that's
what i'm going for right and there's
this passion that animates us it's like
man as christians you know this is my
slogan like make christians peculiar
again that's the slogan
like that's what i'm going for i want us
to be weird right and not because we're
intentionally trying to be eccentric but
because we're like trying to be
christ-like
and
that becomes an odd thing now um i get
you know peter's writing of course 2000
years ago we can kind of wonder like i
don't know how does this translator how
does this bridge like today though
and um
we have to understand though is that
peter his audience right he's writing to
a church in rome
right now if you know anything about the
roman empire
wow
that's a powerful empire it was the
single most powerful influential culture
of that time
which means if you were born and raised
in that culture like it's hard not to be
just bought in
right and and so this is where i think
it's a not a hard
um bridge right a gap to bridge between
kind of who peter's writing to and um
and us
today
um
and and i think this is why he just
keeps hammering home on these things
right remember you're strangers you're
foreigners you're exiles you're the
people of god you're a holy priesthood
you're you know he just keeps going and
maybe some of you feel like oh my gosh
this is like part two of that same
message yep maybe be a part three you
know just like we just keep
what's he doing because he's trying to
remind them of who they really are
right because a culture that just it
just sweeps us
um away
um it's it's almost like he's trying to
say like church don't forget to be in
step with christ
to be in step with christ is of course
you love right it's to love your people
your family your tribe your nation like
yes you love
and yet you also find yourself
consistently out of step with them
if you're not consistently out of step
then it makes me kind of question well
then are we in step with christ
does that make sense right so to be in
stuff with christ it kind of takes us
out of step with um with culture so um
i felt like in my last message where we
kind of went into all these themes i
kept a little more high level so tonight
what i want to do is drill down a little
bit like i want to get a little more
practical because i think at a high
level we could all kind of nod our heads
like yeah brother amen and stuff but we
could also kind of ask the question like
yeah so what do you actually mean though
you know like what how does that
actually look
so what i want to do is go back to the
early church i want to look at three
kind of um things that made the early
church very peculiar and then i think
the application i think the way it
bridges to us today will become
somewhat clear
so um three ways all right first way
first example is that christians
were weirdly
unpatriotic
or weirdly unpatriotic don't worry i'll
offend everyone tonight so
um
so something there was something
operating in rome at the time peter
before peter's writing well after he was
writing um it was called the imperial
cult in rome it was basically emperor
worship
and through by worshiping the emperor
you worshipped the whole
empire
and um
in fact there's a fascinating little
inscription that archaeologists found um
and they found it in this kind of
outlying roman province it's known as i
think you pronounce it the priyan
inscription
and just listen to the language so this
is basically it's a piece of imperial
propaganda that they like chiseled into
stone in one of the cities so as people
walked by they'd read it you know kind
of get the message
so here here it is
the most divine caesar
we should consider equal to the
beginning of all things for when
everything was falling into disorder and
tending toward dissolution he restored
it once more and gave the whole world a
new aspect caesar who being sent to us
in our descendants as
savior
this sounds familiar
has put an end to war he has set all
things in order and we're as having
become god manifest caesar has fulfilled
all the hopes of earlier times the
birthday of the god augustus has been
for the whole world the beginning of
good news
it is literally in greek you angelia
gospel
concerning him
does that sound familiar so what do
christians do they took all that
language and all the titles of caesar
and then what did they do
they said and that describes
perfectly the lord jesus christ
he is the beginning of all things he is
god manifest he is god with us he is the
true savior in fact there was a little
term going around back in the ancient
world it was caesar is lord
that was the phrase caesar is lord does
this sound familiar
because what they do they took it they
just grabbed it right out of culture and
they said well
that is almost correct and they said no
no except that it's jesus jesus is lord
jesus is savior jesus is the beginning
of all things he's god manifest he is
the one who brings the true peace not
the beast of rome
which always happens through war
but the true
peace
can you see how this wasn't overly
popular
at the time i mean you think maybe i was
i don't know exaggerated or something
but when you read that it's like no no
they were yeah this wasn't hugely
popular for the christians to do and and
why because they wouldn't worship they
wouldn't worship caesar they wouldn't
say rome is the hope of the world
just wouldn't they wouldn't do it they
just wouldn't get on board
and it aggravated people i was like
come on we're trying to hold the empire
together here can't get these darn
christians on the same page
you know they're so pesky
so pesky amen
thank god
okay so what is this how does this
translate i think in a lot of ways you
know i mean obviously at one sense it's
not complete apples to apples in a sense
we're not like commanded to worship you
know the president or commanded by law
and they were like you had to do this
you had to do the pinch of incense as
you entered certain governmental
buildings and throw it to caesar and
sort of like a little moment of worship
and the christians wouldn't do it and so
and it was like legal and that's where
they got persecuted it became a whole
thing
um so obviously it's not exactly apples
to apples in essence we're not commanded
by law to worship you know bow the knee
to biden or trump or you know whatever
we have to do that um
and yet and yet and yet right there's
then we have all these little ways um
where the kind of the nation state it's
like hey
get on board here
you know i mean well heck we don't have
to be commanded i mean you've seen some
of the news articles and clippings and
like there's just a whole movement where
we just it's just very easy to start
aligning the movement of god the
movement of the spirit and to then kind
of say and how that's happening today
is through politician xyz
and so come on everyone get on board you
know and it's like we just started
before you know it it's like
um
there's just a whole movement
of christians kind of
it almost starts to sound like america
is lord
right that's basically what happens
enough that i think if like early
christians were to somehow be magically
transported to today and they all saw us
you know pledging allegiance and doing
the whole thing i think they would just
sort of i think the eyebrows would come
up i'll just say that so the eyebrows
are up kind of like
okay it's a little uncomfortable for me
you know i think i'm imagining that's
how they'd see it um or like here's a
fascinating example it's the whole um
with kaepernick
right and the the kneeling
and this became a whole thing um now i'm
not focusing so much on the kind of
racial injustice dimensions that would
be maybe another sermon because i think
there's a lot there what i want to point
out
is that um
it's it's interesting that what was
really what kaepernick was really being
called into question um
and just to make sure i think everyone's
on the same page where he was the
quarterback who would not stand for the
national anthem but would kneel during
it and this became the whole thing right
i think 99 of you know just for that one
person who's like i've been not in
america or whatever you know you don't
know okay so that became a whole thing
now here's what's interesting who was at
the very vanguard
of the movement
to say no kaepernick how dare you that's
disrespectful and you're not you're not
honoring the nation like you're not who
is at the very vanguard like this the
tip of the spear for that movement
christians
right can you see how um
we could get into a whole conversation
on like well you know what can
christians do can they sing the
the national anthem or can they pledge
allegiance or you know that's i think
that would be interesting i think that's
a cool conversation that as christians
we need to be having among each other
i'm not even naming just that i'm saying
it's interesting that
sort of the litmus test
for whether you're like our true
american like the the test was being
kind of proctored by christians
right and that's the thing that's just i
think early christians they could be
transported here they'd just be like
huh
that is so weird
like i don't get i don't get it
i don't get why
why you feel like like if that's the
thing you're passionate about like
that's the thing that takes you to level
10 emotion
right i think that's that's the that's
where early christians would be like we
could have a conversation about what can
you kneel or you know
but why do you have such a point because
a pony in that race why because for
early christians once you whit went
under the baptismal waters
and they came up a new creation you have
a new
king
king jesus
emperor jesus
jesus is lord
like and that's the thing that matters
that's the focus that's the passion
that's the story we live into
all right so that's first
another light message at the table don't
worry we're gonna keep this one gets
even more chill no not really all right
number two christians were deeply
opposed to infanticide
um in the ancient world to the practice
of like abortion this was like dangerous
you know they didn't they couldn't do
surgeries and things in the ancient
world well um
so instead um what they what they did um
was they would just um
like if a baby were born into a roman
family
there would be a period of days
where um the father of the of the family
kind of the petter familias is how they
say
um
the patriarch of the family would
basically have a few days to decide
whether the child was accepted
into the family
and so they would look for certain
things you know okay is this child like
developmentally kind of quote unquote
normal quote unquote acceptable you know
the things like mental physical
development is this
a good child like this is what they were
trying to decide
um
they would decide based on gender
um so is this the gender we were hoping
for
in this family because in that
especially in the ancient world um males
were sort of more the way um family
inheritance and things like that worked
males were more um
valuable
right
um
so often females were excluded
they would base it just also on just
like is this the right time for us to
have a child
and so based on that the the father of
the family would wait a few days
contemplate then make a decision if they
said yes then the child was accepted and
became an official part of the family if
no um then the child was uh basically
taken to the edge of like the city or
the town
and left to um die of exposure um or
sometimes to be picked up by like could
be brothel owners could be slave traders
who would kind of
knew this was a practice that was
happening and they would pick up the
kids and then you know raise them for
their own purposes
um
so this was the way of the world you
know in the ancient world
and okay so what was the christian
response to this well
um christians they didn't like this and
i think rightly so um they didn't like
this and they they said um
for one
um there's a few reasons one they
believe that every single
person like every single little child
had like in like a certain intrinsic
value
regardless of you know how they
developed or their mental capacity or
just whatever kind of standards people
throughout history have tried to kind of
set to say like oh we're not sure you
know
um they said no no
there's a certain intrinsic value to
every human person why well a few
reasons one jesus died for them
and this was a shift in the ancient
world for like how they thought of
people
and so christians believe jesus died for
them which means like god knows every
person sees every person loves every
person thought enough of them to like
die for them on the cross
and so this shifted how christians
thought
also there's the whole genesis one right
every human person's in some mysterious
way is created in the divine
image
i mean we don't exactly even know what
that means but it's like in some way we
like reflect god
and so christians said like well
this matters every person matters and so
what do they do well two things a um
they forbade their
church members from doing this practice
engage in this practice
um but that wasn't all second
they began actively going out to the
edge of the cities and the towns in the
evenings
and picking up the babies who were left
there
and then they would raise they bring
them into their family and they would
raise them as their own this is part of
the movement that led to like kind of a
um a population explosion among
christians in particular
whereas roman families were like
traditionally smaller and then
christians started having these big
families because they're like
having it you know bringing in all these
kids
and um
this was how the early church um
responded what and now i think it's
interesting and destructive notice what
they didn't do they like didn't go to
rome and start like protesting
and you know shaming people
and shaming mothers and shaming families
and you know how dare you you bad people
like didn't do any of that
what'd they do they just lived their
peculiar way
they just live their peculiar way i
think this is a perfect bridge
like for us in our own world
right we don't use
themes um or the topic of like abortion
we don't use this to shame people to
shame women to shame families
um we don't use this as to score
political points in a culture war
we don't do that we're christians
right we just we live the peculiar
way
um third
third christians cared for the poor
the marginalized and the destitute
um this ties in really closely with the
previous point so i won't belabor it but
um
christians became known for
i mean just being a people who cared for
the lost the least the hurting the
marginalized this became like their kind
of brand so to speak like they were
known for in fact later they would go on
to found the first hospitals in the
entire world
those christians um there's a wonderful
quote this is from the emperor julian um
this is well after peter's writing but
it's still he's a roman emperor and he
said this well he was trying
unsuccessfully to revive worship of the
old pagan gods in rome
and he said this it is disgraceful
when no jew is a beggar and the impious
galileans that's the name given by
juliana christians support our poor in
addition to their own
can you hear some of the frustration in
his voice because basically what he was
trying to do was he was really
frustrated by how this christian
movement was growing and growing and
growing and growing and like the the
temples to apollo and like job and stuff
like they were falling on hard times and
so he's trying to revive it and so we
actually have um
his writings where he wrote to the the
priests of his pagan temples saying like
okay so you're gonna have to start
caring for the poor
because all these christians like this
is what they do and they're making us
look bad
and so now we're gonna have to like
change our ways basically
and uh i love you know why i love this
because this brings us right back to
verse 12. i mean basically we have a
quote
um this is now so julian reign from the
year 361-363 so this is about 300 years
after peter wrote his letter
and you basically have a fulfillment of
peter's words remember what verse 12 was
live such good lives among the pagans
that though they accuse you of doing
wrong so at this time when julian's
writing the christians are being
persecuted
though they accuse you of doing wrong
but they may see your good deeds
and glorify god who is in
heaven
oh church that we could be known
for such a thing again
wouldn't that be marvelous
i came i'll close with this i came
across um
some research this was a number of years
ago the barna organization did like a
whole kind of national five-year study
of christians kind of the state of the
christian faith and they were really
interested in like young people and
specifically why young people were
leaving the faith um they they did
interviews with um like thousands of
young people who
had been in church from early childhood
all the way up to 13 years but then left
around the age of like you know 16 or so
um
and they noted a few things one they
noted that about six out of ten
um young people
will
leave the faith um about that time 16 17
years old will effectively leave and
definitely by their adult years 6 out of
10 won't return
um
which is heartbreaking to think like
even in that room over there
you know
so that's the first insight but second
these same researchers asked those young
people
to describe
the church they were leaving
and these were their three most popular
words
exclusive
unfriendly
and judgmental
exclusive unfriendly judgmental
i mean and keep in mind like
this isn't a survey from like the
outsiders of the church their take on
the insiders you know like no no that's
not who they're interviewing
they were interviewing our children
exclusive unfriendly judgmental you know
what this what this tells me
um
is that what we've been doing
is not
working
like what's happened we have gotten so
in step
with culture
with our tribe
that we have become out of step
with christ
and the end result of that
is that now even our children
say
exclusive unfriendly judgmental
like
yo let's be a peculiar people again
like let's be
the love people
the inclusive people
the compassion people
the justice people
the forgiveness and reconciliation
people
like let's be those people again
we bow your heads close your eyes
let me pray over us
lord jesus make us
your people again your peculiar people
again
jesus help us to see as you see
heal as you heal
love as you love
and forgive as you forgive
help us to pledge allegiance to your
kingdom
and to care for the poor
and the vulnerable among us
in the name of the father
the son
and the holy
spirit amen
[Music]
you guys go ahead and stand with us as
we close with this
hymn you may know it if you are
um raised around hymns but i just felt
like this is a excellent
song for us to
kind of
commit ourselves
to these lyrics as we leave tonight
i have decided
[Music]
to follow jesus
i have decided
[Music]
to follow jesus
no turning back
[Music]
the world
behind me
the cross before
me
the world
behind me
the cross before
me
no turning back
[Music]
no place i would rather be
no place i would be
[Music]
no place i would rather be
no place
[Music]
no other place i'd rather be
still i will follow
[Music]
i will follow
no turning back
[Music]
uh thank you all so much for uh being
with us this evening um if you are in
need of prayer uh i'd be happy to
pray with you um after the service um
also if you're a visitor
that we do have cards in the back and if
you walk down that little corridor
that's right there there's a box we'd
like to know who you are
and there's just a place where you can
just jot down your name and just we just
want to say thank you for joining us
today
also if you are
interested in meetups uh there's also
using that same uh box in the back
there's a place where you can check off
if you're interested in meetups we could
be able to get you connected and
everything like that
and then
just to help us close
um so we're we are going to
share the same benediction because we we
want to make sure that we are sending
you off
um in a way that feels purposeful and we
and i'll just be honest with love
karen's benediction i mean just it just
there's just something about
the way that it just hits home
um and it just touches just each one of
us so um so with that being said
and this is my first time doing this and
no judgment
uh i am reading this though i have not
memorized this yet um so
just with that being said if you want to
just open your hands to receive this
prediction
so you are a child of god
you are a child of god
and this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day
so as you go into this week ahead as
it's yet to be determined with highs and
it's slows and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
thank you
[Music]
you